moi j'ai fait d'un moment la première
fois ci on peut dire que c'était l'amour
parce que c'était pas du gâteau la
première fois c'était avec une fille qui
avait 13 ans et demi
c'était comment ça s'est passé mais on
était tous les d'abord elle aussi
c'était la première fois qu'elle sait
l'amour et moi aussi et
ça a été mal fait mais c'est peut-être
là que j'en garde le meilleur souvenir
pourquoi je sais pas exactement pourquoi
parce que je les considérais cette fille
que maintenant
c'est devenu un peu plus
ça va un peu plus vite tout ça et
je la tâche moins d'importance à quel
âge as tu commencé à avoir des relations
sexuelles à 14 ans avec quelqu'un de
tournage non bien plus logiquement
pourquoi est-ce que tu as eu des
relations sexuelles tu en avais envie
oui j'en avais envie peut-être même un
besoin
c'est toi qui a fait le premier pas non
ce n'est pas moi qui fait le premier pas
c'est lui je crois que je n'aurais pas
pu
quelle est la part de l'amour physique
pour toi est-ce que c'est très important
oui c'est important parce que j'ai la
liaison au moins le même tu te sens
comment tu te sens encore une
adolescente ou une étude je me sens
encore nous doit
les adolescents filles et garçons ont en
général leur premier rapport sexuel dès
l'âge de 14 ans mais le plus souvent
dans de très mauvaises conditions
c'est ainsi que la première relation
sexuelle au lieu de les aplanir les
laisse déçu et désenchanté
enfin moi j'étais assez farouche et
parce que surtout les premières fois
parce que justement je me sentais sans
expérience sur ce sujet et j'avais peur
que ma compagne ne soient pas satisfaits
qu'elle ne dira pas autant de plaisir
que moi j'en tiens alors dans les
premières fois ça a été très dur parce
que j'ai plus tôt c'était c'était
s'était pas les chais ce n'était pas
machine à machine non etc et disons que
j'étais vraiment j'étais serein fille de
coin disons que mais je faisais
attention extrême attention ça fait que
bon mais si elle a pris du plaisir s'ils
ont pris du plaisir d'ailleurs j'en suis
content mais moi je n'ai pas tiré un
plaisir il fallait à tout prix que je
n'ai à décembre pas la première fois que
tu as eu des relations sexuelles s'est
bien passé ah non pas du tout
physiquement pas du tout mais ça n'avait
pas d'importance pour moi disons que je
ne connaissais pas du tout ce que
c'était
ça ne touchait pas ça ne faisait rien je
ne comprenais pas pourquoi on devait
avoir des rapports sexuels je comprenais
pas il fallait c'était comme ça si on
attendait pas du tout du moins que
j'y pensais pas au lendemain c'est venu
comme ça d'un
côté ce que tu as eu ton premier rapport
sexuel
c'est relativement récent c'est ainsi
qu'est ce que tu en as pensé j'étais
tradition étant donné que souvent dans
tous les cas les garçons se cache donc
tout ceci est très rapide et je trouve
que généralement c'est un les gens n'ont
pas le temps d'apprécier finalement tu
n'es jamais eu de relations sexuelles
avec une fille jeu presque envie de dire
malheureusement
tu regrettes agents retraite oui parce
que je pense que sans ça viendra
tiendra au mois d'août mais j'en ai eu
très envie maintenant un peu moins mais
enfin ça dépendra principalement de la
personne car j'ai été très épris des
filles enfin pendant un temps et ensuite
disons que j'ai j'étais un peu déçu
c'est ce qui peut être également à fait
que maintenant je suis uniquement
sécuriser leurs vis-à-vis des garçons
pourquoi tu étais déçu paris c'est pas
ça mais problème mon tempérament qui est
qu'il ya un ascendant très timide et en
fait j'étais j'étais assez handicapée
est en fait une fille pas tellement
comprendre ce genre de handicap et alors
je passais à côté de nombreuses
occasions lorsque j'avais 13 14 ans et
en fait après le jeu trouve avec des
garçons alors là c'était beaucoup plus
facile ben disons que c'était parce que
j'en attendais c'est la manière dont ça
s'est passé qui m'a déçu tu as tellement
ce que j'attendais finalement c'est tous
les à côtés toute la compréhension tout
toutes les contraintes aussi la peur la
pomme la peur des parents puis la peur
aussi de livrer quelque chose qui est
des personnels finalement très qu'est ce
que tu crois que les filles et les
garçons et d'une façon différente
non je pense pas du tout
les filles sont plus attirés par tout ce
qui
assez futile aux yeux des garçons
d'ailleurs enfin c'est à dire les
caresses les attentions les la
compréhension et je pense que là est la
seule différence c'est à dire que parce
que les garçons sont beaucoup plus terre
à terre en disant qu' il se satisfait il
se dit s'ils se satisfont
facilement
sont très vite et satisfait simplement
parce que l'année de l'afrique est à
côté et jolie ou autre comme ça quoi ça
suffit pour eux le plaisir d'être
primaire est ce que tu crois que c'est
l'attitude très souvent des filles qui
sont presque obligé de répondre au désir
de l'homme enfin moi je pense que c'est
souvent ça et c'est dommage parce que ça
devrait être quelque chose qu'on fait un
conte choisi mme qu'on décide de faire
ensemble et pas parce qu'un on a envie
et puis parce que bon finalement rouler
même quand même alors si c'est le moyen
de le garder bouma d'accord mais enfin
ouais ouais je pense que c'est très
souvent l'attitude qu'adapter les filles
je vois moi je sorte avec un garçon qui
était banque était très très beau qui
était oui il n'était pas intelligent et
lui ce qui compte est chez les filles
c'était vraiment faire l'amour avec avec
elle et il m'a demandé à maintes
reprises sur deux jours j'ai pas voulu
madigou 20
à 20 ans je vais aller voir je vais
aller voir ailleurs alors je veux pas
tellement d'intérêt mais tu ne t'es
steam pas trop jeune quand même pour
faire l'amour non non puisque je le
ressens pour que je n'ai envie ton
besoin puisque comme tout et ça tue
quelle part tu as dans l'amour tu
actives tué passif sur un trou au désir
de l'homme main sur ces actifs
l'épanouissement physique c'est ce que
tu recherches avant tout je lis
recherché je les trouvais le défi avec
qui je passerai pas mal de temps avec et
puis en art ou j'aime bien m'amuser
c'est à dire que je vais dans une soirée
ou en boîte ou n'importe où jouer une
fille qui me plaît bon ben ce qui
m'amuse c'est d'aller la voir et puis
d'inviter un slot et puis dû sortir le
baratin et puis deux
enfin de faire le reste quoi et puis
passer la soirée avec elle et puis si ça
va pas si elle me convient pas si elle
est pas marrant parce que moi il me faut
des films à rendre pour la soirée c'est
ce qu'il faut aux tendances et si elle
est pas marrante bon bah je vais voir
ailleurs je suis dit bon mais ça y est
c'est terminé et puis je vais voir
ailleurs c'est un de [ __ ] mais c'est
comme ça les garçons ton âge tout de
suite il te demande de coucher avec eux
ouais
ça ça te choque
trouve pas ringard et tout de suite puis
pour ça et toi il s'appelle
fait jamais demandé tout de suite je
préfère les garçons de mon âge pourquoi
bien les grands fin dès que ça fait 20
ans mène 2 1 samedi respiro plus
confiance me font peur justement je vois
cette image du garçon qui le premier
jour qui sera avec la fille va tout prix
avoir des relations avec elle ça me
ferait peur au départ quand j'ai
commencé à sortir avec des filles
c'était très agréable pour moi de sortir
avec viseur fille d'à la fois parce que
c'était le chargement qui primait
c'était c'était très bien quoi un fait
part par la suite je me suis rendu
compte que les filles avec qui je sors
tes oreilles tu pouvais mais c'est à
dire que j'aurais pu les décevoir si
elle apprenait que justement il avait
d'autres y avait d'autres fils à ma vie
alors
j'ai décidé tout bonnement de cesser ce
genre
d'activités en tenant compte simplement
des sentiments de d'une fine et moi je
préfère je préfère parce que tant
d'années je me lasse vite une fille
je vais je veux en voir une si je peux
aller en voir une autre après pour moi
cc c'est bien mieux parce que j'arrive à
connaître plus de plus de monde qui
arrive à communiquer à avoir un contact
encore plus générale sur plusieurs
filles qui me permet de faire une
synthèse et devait recevoir des sorties
certaines petites choses qui peuvent
clocher avec une fille que je ferais
mieux de de la laisser voilà si une
fille a le même comportement
si elle sort avec plusieurs garçons à la
fois et si elle fait facilement l'amour
qu'est ce que vous pensez tél bon
d'abord les jeunes en général parce que
c'est vraiment la dernière définit
qu'un téléphone ça en fait moi je pense
que je pense pas du tout pareil je pense
que aller exactement dans el pais el
pais est dans le même cas qu'un garçon
et dans ce cas là les jambes le juste un
garçon comme un gars dragueur à la
limite et voilà et moi je le tourisme à
faire ainsi qu'un effet mai
la condition peut-être xps ça m'est
jamais arrivé alors peut-être je pense
et ça parce que c'est un peu mince à
méchaal est arrivé c'est pour ça elle
son ascendance dans leur droit et
pourquoi pas pourquoi est-ce qu'elle ne
ferait pas comme comme nous ont fait et
d'abord je crois que c'est un peu à
cause des parents ainsi qui
là il ya un problème aussi qu'ils se
posent les filles il faut déjà qu'elle
reste chez elle qu'elle qu'elles sortent
moins que garçons et sache que je trouve
ça complètement stupide car au fond et
sont venus sur terre c'est à égalité et
c'est là que il ya des différences
[Musique]